é de 1997 ser desafiador havia me levado
dois meses antes para realização de um
dos meus sonhos está trabalhando em
ambiente internacional naquele domingo
minha vida estava exatamente onde eu
queria o quase no final da tarde do dia
anterior o sábado minha equipe um gente
da Índia Bangladesh Uruguai Nigéria
Bulgária havia recebido um grupo de
moradores de uma aldeia que havia sido
supostamente atacada por um bando
errante nome que se dá às crianças que
têm as suas famílias mortas e passam a
ser os meninos soldados de uma guerra
que não é deles mas era um final de
tarde aluno
não vamos permitir naquele território
angolano fazer investigações depois que
escurecer estaremos completamente
desprotegidos e sem possibilidade de
resgate descemos que iríamos no outro
dia o grupo se forem satisfeito mas nós
nos comprometemos a estar mais cedo
possível naquela Aldeia atacada só no
outro dia como combinado já estávamos
preparados a 5 horas da manhã e assim
que o sol nasceu fomos eu então
tenente-coronel Rosália uruguaio muito
bacana muito inteligente gostava de
dançar nós chegamos a uma cidade chamada
clima eu falei com o representante da
Guerrilha ou representantes da polícia e
as 6 horas da manhã nós iniciaremos a
nossa missão
nós fomos abordados no meio do caminho
por uma Land Rover com umas 20 pessoas
lá na carroceria atrás um facões pedaços
de pau barras de ferro e neste momento
nós percebemos que havia é muito ódio
nos seus olhos no seu gestos é o que a
guerra desenha era a luta pela tão
sonhada sobrevivência nós descobrimos
depois que o mesmo grupo que tinha feito
ataque voltou para odeia eles
completarão as suas atrocidades e
fizeram pior queimando todo alimento que
estava guardado e fazendo coisas
inimagináveis com mulheres e crianças
Resumindo com 26 anos eu seria morto e
inchado mas eu escolhi que naquele
momento não seria o instante correto eu
pensei eu tenho que ver o meu primeiro
filho nasceu tem que voltar para casa
e eu tenho que criar os meus próximos
fiz e como é que eu sair dessa bom
usando a minha experiência como dizer da
cabine de som a gente aprende a
compreender o sentimento das pessoas e o
movimento lendo os corpos lendo as
mentes a comunicação no silêncio é a
distância que vira aproximação e foi
isso que eu fiz fui na direção do membro
mais agressivo do grupo ele batia uma
barra de ferro no chão com muita força
soltava faíscas Eu Me Lembro até hoje
mas eu precisava sair dali eu tô aqui
isso significa que eu consegui eu penso
as imagens na minha mente eu fiz o que
pude o agradecimento veio depois de ir
naquela Aldeia e dividir com o chefe
dali a única refeição que ele tinha para
passar as próximas 48 horas por um
momento emblemático na minha vida
e esse momento ele deixar cicatrizes
profundas mas você tem cicatrizes é
porque a filha da sala no cause no
desespero você tem que ter visão você
precisa compreender e usar em seu favor
tudo que aquela crise tiver eu usei eu
identifiquei uma oportunidade entre os
piores agressores eu mostrei que as
minhas ações eram direcionadas para eles
apresentam uma solução para apoiá-los e
principalmente para acolhê-los eu
entendi que a solução deveria contemplar
a todos mas como fazer isso para a sua
vida e falar sobre isso em 2020 eu
descobri que na crise você tem que usar
o código Preto
não existe um silêncio narrativo do
Impossível a sua vida inicialmente
determinada pelo histórico dos elementos
sociais que cercam e a complicado se
desviar disso para muita gente eu não
sei se vocês perceberam né negão
pretinho filho de pais desquitados nos
anos 70 isso era muito complicado os
pais separados a mãe que cultuava uma
religião de matriz africana então o
pretinho filho da macumbeira pai fora da
caixa era Sargento mais fez faculdade
com o superior um outro Sacrilégio
criado pela dor ou a nossa secretária lá
em casa e pelos meus dois irmãos mais
velhos tudo maravilhoso eu vivia
limpinho cheiroso falavam as palavras
difíceis gostava muito de ler e queria
escrever um livro com meu amigo Horizon
isso me tornava diferente
é uma corrida minimamente justa Todos
deveriam partir do mesmo Ponto de origem
merece não chegar primeiro aquele que
tivesse A melhor performance mas o que
fazer para ganhar a prova quando o seu
ponto de partida começa uma curva lá
trás bem distante de todos os outros
corredores é algo que você não consegue
mudar eu tinha que ser diferente a minha
crise era constante E é exatamente ali
que eu precisava mudar tudo Rio e Ford
no início dos anos 1920 o seguinte os
meus clientes podem ter qualquer carro
ou Carlos de qualquer cor desde que
sejam Preto
tá bom essa frase original tem diversos
significados para muita gente quando se
fala de alguém que mudou a sociedade
mudou a classe média naquele período a
excelência ela começou quando se viu a
necessidade de criar uma plataforma que
fosse útil que contemplasse muitas
pessoas que melhorasse os resultados e
pudesse ser escalável pudesse expandir
ou seja tivesse uma distribuição de
produção que fosse massiva naquele
momento GM Ford ressignificou as
dificuldades dele usou o código Preto
dos casos e você tem como aproveitar o
fato de estar na crise na sua crise e
ressignifica-la foi que eu fiz com a
minha
E para isso é muito importante que você
lembre desse 7 passos do que nós vamos
falar agora na crise você vai entender
exatamente onde você pode chegar a
partir dessa experiência que eu vou
compartilhar com você na crise isso tem
que ter um significado para você o n
significa não avance sem um propósito
nós estamos em um mundo que muda muito
estamos em um mundo vuca volátil é
incerto complexo e amigo mas ele precisa
ser corrigido com ovo caprime que ao
antigo tudo nós temos que ter visão
temos que ter entendimento temos que ter
clareza e temos que ter agilidade mas o
futurólogo David bolos ele mostra para
nós de forma muito importante que nós
precisamos cuidar para que não caiamos
em uma armadilha de todo muito
exponencial
é muito ágil imagine-se sem um
planejamento sem uma visão seu
entendimento sem essa clareza e sem essa
agilidade que você se desloca em
altíssima velocidade buscando o
exponencial querendo ser muito ágil mais
para a direção errada então não se
esqueça disso n tem que significar não
avance sem um propósito lá no seu na
crise também tem um significado oa
significa Aceite o fracasso troque pela
resiliência E alcance a antifragilidade
Brasília é o melhor local para
compreender como fracassar o tempo e
circunstâncias alteraram Quatro Pilares
importantes da nossa sociedade política
dinheiro poder e justiça aqui a política
ela não se traduzem ajuda em diversos
momentos o dinheiro não chega
e o poder não se encontra com a
prosperidade e a justiça ela não
equilibra o convívio social isso tudo é
um aprendizado portanto saiba que o
impacto ele vai ocorrer você deve ser
resiliente deve absorvê-lo mas ele não
precisa se repetir esquive-se dos
próximos impactos e aproveite a mudança
de direção para aproximar-se do que te
desafio do que te leva com isso com esse
aprendizado você se mostrar a anti
frágil
e o Cia da sua crise ele significa que
curiosidade não mata buscar conhecimento
além do ortodoxo isso sim se aproximará
da sabedoria e escreva e adapte
informações para o seu uso isso é a
modelagem isso tem que ser o seu novo
rack a sua nova habilidade o r da crise
significa que o risco vale a pena para o
que você acredita e para os seus valores
com Juliano cartacho e Samuca Melo nós
fizemos um vídeo viralizar com mais de
um milhão de visualizações e houve
durante quase que uma semana curiosidade
para que se chegasse a um entendimento
de uma ocorrência positiva que naquela
época era muito difícil de ser colocada
na televisão isso eu falo né de uma
maneira geral agora e se eu estiver
falando dos meus valores eu abandonei o
cargo de subcomandante geral da
Corporação por quê Porque eu entendia
que o
um simples estavam vinculados as pessoas
a sociedade aos policiais aos homens e
mulheres que eu liderava e não há outros
interesses foi um risco para minha
carreira assim foi o risco da mesma
maneira que divulgar aquele vídeo e
segurá-lo por uma semana também foi mas
o risco faz parte do seu sucesso faz
parte desse código PIN to inspire ações
pessoas não organizações
e as ações elas não dependem
exclusivamente das organizações das
instituições foque nas pessoas esse da
sua crise significa inspirar pessoas
ações feitas por pessoas mudam
Organizações e eu percebi isso muito
perto o seu Écio Écio da sua crise
significa seja disruptivo uma palavra
bonita para de repente você se alguém
abusado O som tá muito ruim daqui a
pouco eu entro na cabine vira DJ e ver e
comecei a sua os 15 para 16 anos não
adianta tentar não só vai de Capitão
para cima como Tenente eu fui para minha
primeira missão de paz fui abusado a
gente precisa de você por Discovery
Channel no programa 2111 também a partir
de uma iniciativa de um abuso Você Vai
representar as Polícias e corpos de
Bombeiros Militares do Brasil na onde
você vai sentar naquela cadeira e foi
exatamente isso que aconteceu então
Olá seja disruptivo uf significa
Exatamente isso seja usado
É ué da sua crise ecossistemas só
evoluem quando alterados eu aprendi isso
Criei um Security tour viage pelo mundo
inteiro buscando condições de segurança
diferentes para a população mas eu
busquei pessoas quando criei o
credenciado Segurança Internacional para
que mudasse a cabeça de quem o desejava
que movimentasse o mundo de uma outra
fórmula Esse é o código preto mas muita
gente também utiliza esse mesmo código
às vezes até sem saber eu trago você de
novo para angola no ano de 1997 quando
30 crianças fariam uma apresentação para
um grupo de pessoas de diversas
nacionalidades E esse grupo estava
dentro de um quartel dentro de uma
unidade militar Portuguesa era uma
comemoração de uma data Lusitana muito
importante
a cola em relação ao clima é muito
parecida com o Brasil final do ano final
de outubro e início de novembro começam
aquelas chuvas mas eu não sei se vocês
tem conhecimento mas Angola também é um
dos países como a quantidade de minas
terrestres no mundo as crianças que
vinham fazer essa apresentação para nós
temos seus quatro cinco seis sete
aninhos passavam por cima de um campo de
futebol e aquela Chuva de Novembro
trouxe a terra que ficava concentrada
naquele campo trazendo a terra
descobriu-se uma mina uma explosão surda
muitas daquelas crianças completamente
dilacerado se a Mina Terrestre ela é
muito complicada é muito cruel ela
retira a parte ela mochila artes do
corpo ela cria infecções ela faz com que
Artes dos Ossos penetrem
bom e quando não se morre daquela
amputação existem graves problemas com
as infecções bom aquela é uma área com
uma condição de suportar as necessidades
hospitalares de forma diferente as
crianças vieram sim para que a unidade
militar portuguesa nós passamos por um
período caótico de aproximadamente 30
minutos onde todas as crianças estavam
sendo socorridas fui uma crise
em determinado momento quando todos já
pensavam ir embora nós começávamos a
escutar um som de alguns tambores uma
música suave as poucas crianças que não
haviam sido machucados mutiladas tinham
que continuar o seu propósito elas
subirão a um Palco improvisado
continuaram cantando As duas músicas que
tinham ensaiado e nos trouxeram alegria
que elas podiam para mudar o nosso mundo
nós éramos os convidados É nesse momento
que eu te convido para que você se
pergunte como você vai mudar o seu mundo
qual é o seu código preto e te pergunto
mais vai usar ou não vai usar essa
expressão na crise porque assim todas as
vezes que ele questionarem o que mais
você vai ter as
a próxima resposta de mudança na ponta
da língua né
[Música]